on the third day of his trial for
domestic abuse Ryan Giggs heard the
woman who alleges he assaulted and
attacked her face the questions of his
legal team they called what she's told
to court rubbish and a pack of Lies
Kate greville was asked about an
incident in which she claimed Mr Giggs
dragged her naked from a hotel room she
was asked why she exchanged affectionate
messages with him in the following days
and didn't mention any violence she told
the jury it's difficult to explain we
had this turbulent relationship
obviously we had this argument but I
desperately wanted this relationship to
go back to the way it was I was in
denial about actually what had happened
I would never talk to him about it I
would never write anything in a message
because I wanted to forget that it
happened but it isn't a pack of Lies
Miss greville was asked about bruises
that she said were caused by the
violence at the time she accepted she'd
been texting Mr Giggs saying those
bruises had come about during sex she
said she hadn't mentioned that they were
caused by violence because she was
embarrassed and didn't want to admit it
she said it wasn't public profile or
wealth that attracted her to Mr Giggs
him being a footballer actually put her
off she said but his success she did
find attractive she told police though
she felt she'd become a slave to his
every need and demand that's how I felt
she told the court
Miss gravel has already described the
alleged assault of the couple's home in
November 2020 where she alleges he
head-butted her he's also accused of
coercive and controlling Behavior
Ryan Giggs denies the charges before
court ended for the day Kate greville
admitted deleting messages but she said
she told the truth 100 her evidence
continues Greg Milam Sky News Manchester